is it ever like a
frustrating when because you know we
we're we're kind of in the same thing
but we're all like our own unique kind
of channel and whatnot is it ever like a
a frustrating thing that you know
because you obviously all the v tubers
come in as one package it's like this is
the generation how do you make sure that
there's not this kind of weird sense of
competition amongst fellow youtubers
because you're all kind of the same
thing right and you're not i mean you're
not the same but you're you're the same
target audience right yeah joey talks
about manga not anime and i i might go
and do something silly right or
something about faye you know it's
totally different audience even though
we are kind of in the same market right
yeah yeah with v tubing i always wonder
how how do you like stop that from
happening like a competition like that
ah you know
it's hard for me to speak on behalf of
the entire v tuberculosis
as much as i support and love like the
work of what indies are doing i don't
have enough energy in my life to go
socialize with many outside of holo
which i think is a shame and i wish i
could but it's just it's kind of
difficult to do so i can really only
speak about what i've seen within holo
but um
i just feel like
somehow there was there was some kind of
magic involved in the in the selection
process where they just
they chose people
that we just we just don't really
get extra jealous of each other i mean
it's good at least this is me saying
from my perspective i don't know what's
going through the other side
i can't speak on their behalf but i can
say from me um genuinely the people that
they chose i look at them and i just
want to see them succeed
i feel like part of me is is questioning
like well shouldn't you be wanting to be
better than x and so and so but i can't
i just can't parse that feeling i just
don't feel it that is the truth i mean
of course there's me wanting to be my
best but i guess here's a good example i
can give you from my past
i had my first my first really really
close friend ever was a friend that i
met in middle school who was the new kid
she moved to my city i had no friends in
that school um it was not great but this
new kid came and she was drawing she had
a how to draw manga book
hell yeah and um i had been trying to
figure out like what is that art style
called because i didn't know where to
search for it i was young i had no idea
and so she explained it to me she opened
up the whole world to me and she let me
borrow it and that was when i started
drawing and i came to school the next
day and people were like wow
you can draw really well you both are
really good some people were saying
callie you're actually
you you really you're you're maybe a
little better and i was like no that's
not true but that was like that was the
feeling that i got of
i can do something
i i can do something and be good at it
and people are you know looking at what
i'm doing and then of course my friend
was also like
oh hell yeah let's let's learn together
and we became friendly rivals in that
like we were always kind of working
alongside each other drawing and like
you know maybe you show your friend a
picture you drew hey this is my original
character oh cool here's mine and like
you're still friends but like there's
this feeling of i gotta keep up with
this person you know and as i started
being involved in more art communities
as i as i grew older and you know met
friends on the internet et cetera we all
were still cool and friends with each
other but seeing others hard work
made us want to keep up
that kind of thing so and so do this
well i want to i want to try doing that
let me see how how i can do you know so
it's not like an outright feeling of
jealousy but it's a feeling of wanting
to like make yourself better to keep up
i guess and it's like friendly
competition you know just that's good
yeah that sounds very healthy yeah
that's how it was for me personally
so no bad feelings that's right that was
a very good answer dude
that's the most wholesome yeah yeah yeah
i was i was like you know waiting for
the blood to be spilled
that kind of like healthy competition
can form i think yeah you know instead
of like a wide group of people competing
together like a death game you know for
example death games on the mind sorry
guys
i was going to say back on the death
games
but if it's like a small group of
friends it's really easy to foster like
a a healthy competition yeah i think
it's that like whole mentality that a
lot of people still
you know struggle to understand of like
if one person succeeds then you know the
rest can also come up yeah kind of
mentality and i feel that like at least
on like youtube and stuff like that and
probably you know in the youtuber
community as well where it's like if one
v tuber succeeds then everyone in that
same genre can also kind of rise up
together as a community and i feel
though as especially like a lot of the
smaller creators still don't quite
understand that yet i think in my eyes
like where it's like i know i need to be
better than this person well the the
normally the biggest channel in any
genre is an indication of
you know the the size you can get the
cap off yeah it's normally a good way so
you know if someone at the top is
blowing up that's normally a good thing
yeah yeah exactly more audience to
trickle down like i wouldn't have come
back to youtube if i didn't see joey
blowing up because i thought i thought
when i quit youtube i'd like reach the
ceiling my crown back
i was the guinea pig
it's like wow he's made a fart yeah
because i was just like i thought that i
had reached the ceiling of anime content
on youtube and at the time i had because
anime just wasn't as popular so i'm just
then i was like out of the way
i completed youtube
i came back for youtube too
the long-awaited sequel you were saying
kelly sorry
no you're good you're good i was
thinking like
personally i think the most healthy way
to like compete in general though isn't
to think about who you're going to go
past but beating the you of yesterday so
inspirational hashtag wow yeah just
inspirational things hashtag motivated
sounds like a scene out of bucky
you're only as good as how many times
you've had sex
that's backy
that's right but i mean if you think
about it though it really there is some
truth to it as long as you are doing
better than your past self as long as
i'm doing better than past me i feel
good yeah yeah yeah i mean it's very
easy to compare yourself to others and
then hold yourself to an absolute
standard you all want to be the gig of
chat but we can't yeah would you have
like any advice to up and coming
youtubers nowadays now they've had like
a year of a year of experience right
you're a senpai now yeah you are the
senpai now i am um
let's see maybe just i'll pass along
some advice that my senpai had given to
me never stop doing new things
keep
keep trying new stuff
and that's that's the only way to be i
think um is to keep pushing the
boundaries and see what kind of
wonderful stuff can can come from this i
think that's my advice to you guys just
passing on what i've been doing oh yeah
i mean i'd say that's good advice for
like any content creators youtuber or
not